voilà et selon la police
ukrainienne 10 salles de torture aurait
par ailleurs été découverte dans les
zones reprises russes à carquis on va en
parler avec notre invité read Brody
bonjour vous êtes avocat membre de la
Commission Internationale de jury c'est
ancien conseiller juridique également à
Human Right Swatch merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation le
Haut-Commissariat des Nations Unies au
droit de l'homme veut donc envoyer des
observateurs à isum pour enquêter c'est
important d'y aller très vite
il faut savoir exactement quoi nous
avons en face il faut déterminer pour
chaque prochain cours il faut déterminer
les causes du décès il faut
évidemment éplucher toutes les preuves
que nous avons et le plus rapidement
possible avant que les les preuves se
détériorent comment est-ce qu'on mène de
manière pratique une telle enquête sur
des de guerre des crimes contre
l'humanité présumée comment est-ce qu'on
récolte justement ses preuves comment on
établit avec certitude les
responsabilités
avec certitude c'est difficile mais
évidemment les corps souvent présents
des traces que ce soit des traces des
balles il faut voir ce qui est
enterré avec avec les corps est-ce qu'il
y a des balles ce qu'il y a des insignes
et puis dans un deuxième temps il faut
lier c'est
ces décès à
des acteurs et ça c'est probablement
plus difficile s'il n'y a pas de trace
derrière des enfin des uniformes etc il
faut déterminer par exemple
la balle qui était utilisée viennent de
tel tel armée il faut ensuite
voir plus large qu'elle était l'unité
des soldats en charge de cette de cette
zone etc il faut
identifier le plus possible les auteurs
potentiel de ces crimes s'il s'agit des
crimes en l'occurrence le contexte de
guerre qui se poursuit on l'imagine va
rendre le travail beaucoup plus
compliqué
pas nécessairement si l'épreuve sont là
maintenant
déterminer avec exactitude qui était les
soldats qui étaient des commandants quel
ordre ont été donnés c'est évidemment
c'est plus difficile mais comme vous
avez dit nous sommes en face en fait
d'une série de crimes une série de
massacres donc on va normalement on va
pas s'arrêter avec les soldats ou même
les les
capitains on va aller plus loin on va de
mieux Poutine il voit les mêmes images
que nous est-ce qu'il est intervenu pour
donner des ordres qu'on arrête ces
massacres il y a on peut déterminer les
personnes si on peut pas déterminer qui
les autres on peut quand même déterminer
la chaîne de commandement si un
commandant voit que ces troupes sont en
train de commettre des atrocités et
n'intervient pas pour les arrêter il
devient aussi lui responsable comme
responsable hiérarchique donc les
commandants russes voient les massacres
à boutcha à Mario Paul est-ce qu'ils ont
donné des ordres de respecter la vie des
civils est-ce qu'ils ont donné est-ce
qu'ils ont traduit en justice ceux qui
sont accusés des crimes donc tout cela
peut jouer pour déterminer non seulement
les responsabilités des petits soldats
sinon les responsabilités de ce qui ont
la commande de ces soldats Rick Brody de
manière générale depuis le début de la
guerre en Ukraine on a le sentiment que
la justice internationale se saisit
quand même rapidement quand il y a des
cas présumés de crimes de guerre de
crime contre l'humanité
on n'a jamais dans l'histoire que je
sache on n'a jamais vu une telle
mobilisation internationale en faveur de
la justice nous avons l'accord pénal
international nous avons évidemment le
procureur Ukranien qui a ouvert des
milliers de cas on a aussi une douzaine
de pays comme la France qui ont ouvert
des enquêtes ou qui ont envoyé des des
spécialistes sur place les Nations Unies
etc on n'a jamais vu une telle
mobilisation de la justice
internationale comme maintenant vous
évoquiez notamment l'enquête de la Cour
pénale internationale qui s'était
ouverte en mars
on sait où on est cette enquête et
comment est-ce que cette enquête disons
est menée en parallèle aux autres
comment est-ce que ça se passe
concrètement bon nous ne savons pas
parce que c'est le secret de l'enquête
on sait pas où ils en sont nous
près de des procureurs merci beaucoup
ride Brody pour votre éclairage
aujourd'hui sur notre